scottson atlanta hi Scott welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show Dave Ramsey merry
Christmas to you
merry Christmas to you sir how can I
help I want to tell you that I started
driving lyft as a side hustle and I used
the time that I'm in the car to listen
to your podcast as inspiration and to
remind me why I'm doing it so thank you
well thank you how can I help so my
parents are in their late 70s and they
did an awful job planning for retirement
they've got a reverse mortgage they
filed bankruptcy several years ago
they're on Social Security they both
still work they're in a debt
consolidation plan they've done
everything wrong and this will not be me
my wife and I our baby step two we've
been through Financial Peace University
we've got a little over two hundred
thousand dollars to pay off not
including our mortgage or so we'll be
there in 37 months to do our debt free
scream Wow
my parents called me and needed to
borrow money last week they haven't made
a habit but it's not the first time and
so it derailed us for the month we had
to work it into our December budget
which is the worst of the year it did
add to my intensity and I had a long
conversation with them about not
supporting their unsustainable lifestyle
well I'm busting my hump trying to work
15 hours a day to get out of debt Wow
long story short of that conversation
gonna be actually get them FPU yeah
how'd that conversation go I you know I
kind of felt like their parents when we
were talking about it like you were
scolding them yeah but you know the
tables have turned financially and you
know
yes I'm able to give them the $500 they
needed but I told them that I can't make
it habit out of doing it and I won't
because I've got my own problems to take
care of too
[Music]
the real question here is I thought of
getting them FPU but at almost 80 years
old and on what's basically a fixed and
very low income I don't know if it makes
sense at their age and income level well
if they learned to be proactive with
money and they learned to do a budget
with what they have even if they didn't
make a lot of wealth building progress
they probably would gain a sense of
power a sense of peace of mind mm-hmm
but I would I'm with you I wouldn't
project that we're gonna turn these
people into everyday millionaires
I wouldn't even project that necessarily
we're gonna get them out of debt but at
least the money that's coming in from
the horrible reverse mortgage and the
money that's coming in from Social
Security would be managed more carefully
because for their whole life stuff is
snuck up on them right and if we could
get it to where stuff doesn't sneak up
on them anymore they would feel better
they would have a sense of peace you
know when you know when you first start
doing a budget and start making the
money behave it's like I got around in
front of this thing you know finally I
got on top of it it's been on top of me
my whole life now I'm on top of yeah we
flipped it over you know and there's
that sense of gotcha money we're gonna
make you behave instead of you
constantly dictating to us how life
happens and you know that kind of
there's a little bit of that a little
bit of sassiness that you get when you
when you get when you get up on top of
this and if we can help them do that I
would call that a victory I you know I
don't anticipate a big financial move
but if we can get the crisis and some of
the stress and maybe even some of the
shame out of their life by them getting
their handle on what money they do have
coming in it would be worth it I'll give
it to you to give to them okay
that's very kind of you I appreciate it
you think you can get them to go I know
that there are local classes I looked it
up on the website yeah so you know I can
I can give it to them with caveats
we hope that they gotta do the track
yeah they got to go I don't want to
waste it they got to go if they'll go
I'll try to help them with you
it sounds like you got a good heart
towards your mom and dad hey thanks for
calling in hold on Kelly I'll pick up
and we'll get get them signed up